我们在生命中，其实很多时候确实在欺骗自己，用各种方法，怎么能够去冲冲觉醒过来呢？
什么时候我是欺骗自己？能不能说我不在欺骗自己？
我觉得我的生命中就有一个东西牵引着我。
它可能是我所有能量的来源。这个东西就叫做你对真的追求。
大家好，我是少义夫。
大家好，我是杨天真。
很开心啊，今天跟天真在一起。有很多的缘分，
因为如果没有天真的话呢，我们这个播客今天都不会有的，对不对？
然后呢，我们也不会找到小T。
所以今天的话呢，跟你聊聊，我觉得特别开心。
我也是在我生命中特别重要的一个人。
谢谢。
两天以前的时候，我们当时在一个电视会议上，跟一群小伙伴，
他个人趁脑这边大家都有兴趣的一些小伙伴，
看到你就特别的亲切，然后觉得你特别的美，
有一种从心理涌现出来的一种爱的感觉。
所以我第一个问题想问你，天真就说，
你觉得为什么这么多人喜欢你，这么多人把你作为偶像，
很多人follow你，你有一个猜测吗？
为什么？
我想可能是因为我是一个能量比较高的人，
就我比较积极乐观，比较做自己。
其实做一个所谓的公众人物，
你需要提供某些有用的价值给大家。
刚开始呢，我会觉得，哎，我得给大家分享职场上的一些技巧，
得给大家一些干货，这个有用的东西，
可能可以帮助到人，所以可能会有人需要你。
但后来过了一阵子，我就意识到，
其实我这个人，可能对这个社会系统里最大的价值，
就是好好活着，因为我的生活的方式，
主张的东西，我的表达和好多人可能不太一样。
我是一个真的从心底里爱自己的人，
这种爱呢，是不畏惧争议的，
不害怕被讨论的是一种特例独行的，
但是又堵定的爱。
在这个爱自己的过程中，
会有很多的对自己的探索，
然后我又一直把这些探索，
具体的思考跟世界和过程全都分享出来。
所以我想，可能很多人，
确实是因为看到了我这样一种能量，
觉得嗯，不错，想要和这种能量更接近，
当然也同样因为是我这样的表达，
也会有很多人很讨厌我，
会觉得我非常的嚣张，自以为是，
或者过度喜欢赞美自己，
不管是喜欢我的还是不喜欢我的，
我其实都不太在意，
因为一个人如果要想对批评不在意的话，
我觉得他对赞美也得不在意，
就是你不能够只听你喜欢的部分，
你只希望自己被喜欢着，
所以最终我意识到，
我只要活着，
然后充分的做自己就好了。
这过程中如果被喜欢，我感激，
不被喜欢，我也不难过，
因为他们都不太影响，
我就继续这么活着。
我觉得做自己这件事情，
说起来容易做起来很难的，
因为我看到的你呢，是特立独行，
或者不管人家怎么看，
我自己的感受是说，
我原来以为我不太关注别人怎么看我，
如果20年前人家问我说，
关注别人的意见，
我说我是完全不关注的，
我觉得我就是一个理工科的男神，
然后就做事情，
然后完美主义，
然后逻辑性很强，
也不需要什么朋友等等，
但是我慢慢在走自己内心世界以后，
就发现说，
其实在有些角度看，
其实我是蛮在意的，
而且我把在意这个东西，
我自己隐藏着蛮深的，
而上次在你的天真不电视的播客上也讲到，
就是说，
我觉得我自己从前有个蛮强的，
期盼自己的能力，
现在其实你可能也在期盼，
也难说，
我从前觉得说，
我不在意，
有没有朋友，
我觉得我根本无所谓，
但实际上发现说，
其实我很在意，
另外的话，
比如说，
我是不是做好人这件事情，
不太在意，
反正就是，
我就是一个好人就好了，
但其实后来发现说，
我不但在意这件事情，
而且我在最最深处的地方，
会感觉到，
觉得自己在某种角度上，
不是一个好人，
太不够慷慨，
算了东西太惊，
这种行为习惯，
我其实是很讨厌，
厌恶自己的感觉都有的，
甚至有点羞耻感，
不然你有没有过这种感觉，
就说之前的话，
觉得说我都很满意，
然后也不在意怎么看的，
但是过了几个月，
几年是瞬间，
其实我当时是有点在期盼自己的，
有没有这种？
你刚才说的做自己这个词，
这是一个大家经常说的词，
但我觉得这个词非常的精微，
它有两个部分组成，
一个部分叫做，
我觉得做，
它背后意味着合一，
执行合一，
这是很难很难的，
但其实第二个词更难，
就是自己，
就这两年，
包括我自己的思考也好，
核心都在围绕着这个词，
就是什么是自己，
不管我们说的
regular self, true self,。
这个self,
这个自己，
这个在冥想的过程中，
有觉察的和失去觉察的意识，
其实它都是自己的各个层次，
拿到我们现实生活中，
你想要做的事情，
想要做却不敢说出来的想法，
你无法面对自己的真正的想法，
这些到底哪个才是自己呢？
是的,
所以我觉得自己是一个好难好难的概念，
比如说此刻在跟你对话的我，
是我的自己嘛，
这个看着我们对话的那个我，
就是自己嘛，
搞清楚自己的定义，
可能才是做自己的第一步，
但是自己是一个动态的东西，
所以你刚才问我的这个过程，
很多次，
对自己的推翻跟重建，
就我过去认为我是这样的人，
然后发现我不是，
但那些，
当我在说这些话的时候，
我那一刻，
认为那就是我的真实想法，
但是在某一些时刻，
你会有一个惊醒，
那只是一种表述，
你真实的想法，
可能太自私了，
你对自己有批判，
所以你羞辱说出口，
我说的这些羞辱，
不是因为你对人事物有着有，
要伤害的情绪，
而是你对自己有一个道德审判，
另外一种情况，
我觉得更普遍，
就是你有想要的东西，
但是你害怕失去，
你害怕得不到，
你害怕开口了以后被拒绝，
我已经克服了大部分这样的问题，
基本上，
我觉得我想要的，
我都能说出来，
但仍然有着那一部分，
你内心深处的，
你真正的渴望，
所以我觉得做自己，
就是一种搞清楚自己是谁，
并且为着自己想要的东西，
去表达，去付出的过程，
因为很多人在做自己的时候，
他会把它简单的理解为一种任性，
谁也别管着我，
我想吃就吃，想喝就喝，
想睡就睡，
想干嘛就干嘛，
但那不是做自己，
那只是任性，
所以我觉得做自己是一件，
好难好难好难的事情，
刚才这说的时候，
我很感动啊，
我觉得你在讲的时候，
是真的是特别真实的想法，
而且能够这样讲出来，
不容易的，
其实这个时候就是在，
我感觉有点像做自己的感觉吧，
对不对，
你刚才举了一个例子说，
有些东西我们想要的，
但觉得可能永远得不到，
能不能举几个例子啊，
就说你刚才在过程中发现说，
从前是什么东西，
或做什么，
其实是想要但不敢说的，
或者说的东西其实是在假装的，
比如说我们前两年谈到的关于。
Malty Love这个话题，
就是相容之爱，
我两年前，
我们很多同学分享，
都说他们想要这种Malty Love，
我当时是充满恐惧的，
我会觉得，
为什么大家都想要这样强烈的爱啊，
尤其是爱情，亲密关系，
因为你的自己会溶解，
你的自我会消失，
我觉得在一种相容之爱里，
我对他的想象是你的全心全意的付出，
但是是没有控制，
没有边界的一种状态，
经过这两年，
我有了新的感受，
然后,
我可能也就是昨天，
我才会有一种很大的觉察，
我觉得这可能就是我想要的亲密关系，
我觉得他很难，
我就很害怕，
我很害怕自己得不到，
我很害怕自己不会处理，
就是其实基于你的各种害怕，
你会表现出我不需要他，
或者是他不是个好事情，
因为你的害怕，
展现出了对这件事情的攻击性，
但其实你内心是有深深的向往的，
而我是没有办法去表述我对这件事情的向往的，
因为不管是你在谈恋爱的时候，
你有一个对象，
还是你没在谈恋爱的时候，
你跟其他人的表达，
你都想显得自己举中若清，
好像很潇洒，
或者是不会被这种世俗的关系所拖累，
你有一种人设，
那个人设是你给自己想象出来的杀法果断，
我这样讲，
我相信你能理解，
人有的时候是被社会形象塑造的，
这个社会形象，
不是指一定是个公众形象，
它是别人对你的预期，
是你对自己的要求，
你就会有一个想象，
比如说我天然的就会觉得，
我就不应该去追求爱情，
因为爱情是浪费生命的，
你就会对它添加很多的概念，
概念背后到底意味着什么，
你都不清楚，
但是你要用这种概念，
去包装自己的恐惧，
作为人类谁会不想要爱呢，
就谁会不想要一段好的亲密关系呢，
只是因为你得不到，
你用了各种各样的方式去消解它，
比如有的人表现为，
把爱是作为一种交换，
他会误化自己跟他人，
摆出各种条件及衡量，
我一直都很反对这些东西，
但即便我有诸多的反对，
我也很难坦然地说出，
其实我也非常想要这样的melting love，
很难,
但是会经过一些事情和一些时刻，
你会有勇气面对，
原来这才是我真正想要的。
对，是的，天真，
你说这东西是需要很多的勇气的，
一方面勇气是，
跟自己承认我需要这个东西，
另外是在，
包括我们今天现在这边讲到，
你在我们的播客上承认说，
我需要这个东西的话，
其实是需要更大的勇气的，
我也特别说感动，
我们在生命中，
其实很多时候，
确实在欺骗自己，
用各种方法，
可以欺骗自己，
那怎么能够，
去从中觉醒过来呢？
什么时候我是欺骗自己，
能不能说我不在欺骗自己？
我觉得我的生命中，
就有一个东西牵引着我，
它可能是我所有能量的来源，
这个东西就叫做你对，
真的追求，
OK，好，多说说说，
我想多听听，
你看我家天真嘛，
真是一个很宝贵很宝贵的词，
我希望我自己活在真相里，
这个真相不是你的主观定义，
甚至不是摄像机拍摄到的客观场景，
是只有人跟人之间都心知肚明的，
就是这么回事，
很多时候人不追求真相，
是因为幻境，
或者叫做被包装过的表述，
它更能安慰到人，
因为真相有的时候是非常残酷的，
它会击碎你的幻想，
它会让你面对一种赤裸的，
被观察的状态，
而且很多时候，
你掏心掏肺的讲述真相之后，
你也不会得到你的预期，
但我仍然觉得关系必须得面对真相，
就所有的假的东西，
都是不值得投入的，
且会破碎的，
比如说在一段亲密关系里面，
表演成另外一个人，
因为你希望他，
稳定地留在你的关系里，
但是总有一个时刻，
你会意识到，
这样的假装，
让你自己身心聚皮，
让你能量带进，
而你想要的，
你这么努力跟认真付出的，
你想要的是一种被支持的，
被认同的，
被全方面接纳的关系，
所以真是一种至高的追求，
我觉得它高于一切，
高于优我的生活，
高于美丽的外表，
高于外在的条件的，
所有的社会化的认定，
而真这个事情，
它又非常的局限，
因为只有当事人，
只有你们共同经历的人，
才知道那就是真，
真是很宝贵的东西，
但是也很难得获得。
对，对，对，
真的这个追求，
我觉得特别的有共鸣，
自己我感觉是我最大的一个，
如果从性格的角度来，
最大的特点，
可能就是对真的一个追求，
不能说我现在的百分之一，
百是真的，
真是我对真，
也是有同样的很大的追求，
在大概五六年以前，
我碰到一个做内心成长的老师，
他名字叫季，
然后他是一个很资深的老师，
他已经不收徒弟了，
就跟我聊，
聊了大概就半个小时，
他说他愿意收我做徒弟，
我很开心，
因为他很多人听到我，
他是我的老师，
都很羡慕，
过了大概几个月，
我就问他说，
季，你为什么当时收我做徒弟，
已经是关门不收别的徒弟了？
他就说，
他看到我内心有一个火焰，
是the fire for truth,。
就是一种去想去，
追求真的truth的一个火焰在里面，
所以他就觉得，
是愿意收我做徒弟，
我想用一个框架来描述一下，
我们刚才讲的东西，
就是说，
壳这个词嘛，对不对，
从小到大，
一开始就开始建设这个壳，
这个壳的话，
是让我们符合某些人的预期的，
可能是我们父母的预期，
也可能是父母老师的预期，
或者朋友的预期，
或者社交场面的预期，
这样个壳建起来以后，
当然有些壳能量比较大的，
有些可能量比较小的，
相对都是比较，
在小时候是比较自掐的一个壳，
让我们能够在生存的环境下面，
能够获得爱，
没有避免受伤，
但是呢，
当我们年纪越来越大以后的话，
来发现，至少我是感觉上，
发现这个壳，
其实是在限制我很多东西，
让我感受不到很多的东西，
就比如说我从前一个壳，
就是没有什么感情的，
就没有什么感受，
走路上看到花，
我的太太会，
啊，好漂亮，
我就，就这样，
看电影，
我的女儿会在哭，
我就觉得，
她怎么会哭的，
这有什么哭头的，
而且是一种，
比较干巴巴的一种生活，
但这个壳是在保护我，
因为小时候的话，
很伤心的时候的话，
我就不会感受太伤心，
然后呢，
我就慢慢在跟这个壳在做工作，
发现说，
其实这壳，
可能永远不会消散，
我也不要它去消散，
但是呢，
我想跟这个壳有一个新的关系，
就不把我自己当成这个壳了，
而是说，
这壳是我的一个，
可以脱泄自如的一个盔甲，
在有些贤恶的环境里面，
或者怎么样的，
我能把它穿上去，
不需要的时候，
我可以把它脱下来，
那脱下来里面是什么？
把这个脱下来，
那我真正的自我，
是什么？
真我,
真我的探索，
可能是一个，
一辈子的一个事情，
但我现在的感受呢，
是这个真我有，
无限的爱，
无限的勇气，
有慈悲，
有力量，
就你刚才说到，
生活有时候，
确实是很残酷的，
我的感受是，
当我把自己当成，
这个壳的时候呢，
这个壳其实是蛮脆弱的，
需要不停的维护，
然后呢，
出现一些，
残酷的问题的话，
这可能就会被，
击溃,
或者是，
一个很大的伤口，
然后呢，
需要很多时间去治疗，
甚至有时候，
就把这壳更硬了，
再加个一层吧，
当我能够跟我的，
这壳里面的真正的我，
去跟做连接的时候的话呢，
可能已经，
二十年失联了，
甚至五十年失联了，
但是当我跟他，
真正的我，
能够有连接的时候呢，
世界上再多的问题，
再多的，
残酷的事情发生，
我都能够，
比较坦然的，
去应对，
不知道这块，
我讲了这个壳，
跟这个真我的关系，
你有没有共鸣啊，
就说,
或者你说有什么，
觉得不同意的地方？
我换一个表述啊，
我小时候，
特别喜欢看一个动画片，
叫花仙子，
那花仙子呢，
有一把花钥匙，
他每次拿出他的时候呢，
他就可以变身，
他要变身成一个护士，
他拿着那个花钥匙，
变成了那个护士，
有一套很美的衣服，
总之我小时候，
就觉得那把花钥匙，
对一个小女孩来说嘛，
就是你想穿任何衣服，
她都可以帮你实现的，
神气,
等我长大以后呢，
我才忽然意识到，
那个花钥匙，
其实就是你说的那个壳，
我们需要在不同的场合，
去扮演某种角色，
很多人会觉得，
似乎就虚伪了，
但我觉得真我，
并不是一个，
强大的，
无敌的状态，
它是需要被保护的，
它是需要被伪装的甚至，
因为我不觉得真我，
是需要面对所有人的，
它是非常有限的，
空间里跟非常有限的人，
去展示的，
其他时刻，
我们生活在一个动态的，
复杂的，
变化性很多的，
社会性的环境里的时候，
我们需要教一把花钥匙，
让我们在不同的角色中，
去融入，
昨天下午，
我见了一个负担的教授，
叫成果，
成果教授是，
卓雪教授，
我跟他还讨论了，
关于这个爱和自己的一些话题，
我们就讨论到，
每一个人的性格，
到底是天生的，
还是被塑造的，
那被塑造的那个部分，
是你的中文，
还是不是你的中文，
我大概的观点是觉得，
天生的基因领，
肯定是有一些注入的，
但是后天的塑造，
可能才是更重要的事情，
你是急性子，
还是你是个有耐心的人，
其实都是可以被塑造的，
而这个被塑造的一个重要的，
利器就是正反馈，
是的,
就像我从小想说，
数学一样，
得到很多正反馈，
我就更努力，
对，当你做一件事情，
会得到很多的正反馈，
你就会认同自己，
你会愿意得到更多，
你也发现，
你可以轻松的得到更多，
你就会不断的又去努力，
副反馈也是一样的，
就像我认识一个女演员，
她长得很美，
但她家有一个，
长得更帅的哥哥，
所以从小他们家人，
都说她丑，
她其实长得很美的，
但她对自己的外表，
超级不自信，
所以她很吊诡，
这种塑造有的时候，
不是有谁可以去做的，
是有社会环境，
社会价值，
社会比较，
省眉取向，
成功取向等等，
一系列事情塑造的我们，
就像像像平泥一样，
被捏来捏去的过程，
回到你刚才说的那个真我的话题，
我觉得我们不应该做像平泥，
我们应该做一个，
固定的，
坚实的，
身体的谷歌，
但我们可以有很多的花衣裳，
有自己的花钥匙，
我们在不同的场合，
穿上不同的衣服，
去得体的应对这个世界，
但是我们保持内心，
跟自己的连接，
这个我觉得是一种，
我向往的状态。
天真,
你刚才描述这个状态的，
其中一个最大的一个，
起点的话，
是我们知道我们自己，
不是这个花衣裳，
我会想我20年以前的话，
我完全不会想到这件事情，
我实在是想先走这个少一步，
这个人Bow，
英文这个名字的人，
就是这回事，
没什么多弹头的，
我就是我，
我想大家都可以想，
我是这个定义，
自己每个人定义是不一样的，
有一种叛逼，
有一种结构性的思维，
一种行为的习惯，
但是走出的这第一步，
是说我不是这个可，
或者是不同的花衣裳，
这第一步，
当我走出来的话，
就有一个自由了，
然后我们内心的真我是什么，
是不是很坚不可催的，
我现在还不能下定论，
我觉得我的感觉，
是这么说吧，
这个真我是有点是，
在一个一元世界里面的一个东西，
进入这个二元世界了，
然后分化出来这么花花的世界的话呢，
需要一些二元世界的东西去抵挡东西去应付东西，
所以我们确实要去制造一些花衣裳，
做生活中的事情，
但是如果我能够知道，
我不是一些花衣裳，
我自己还有另外一个真正的我的时候的话，
那我就有很大的自由了。
你觉得这个事情的开端是怎么发生的？
因为我们从小的这个神掌过程，
全世界都是这样，人类都一样，
是在什么样的气迹下一个人，
才有可能意识到我的真我，
和我所表现出来的我是不一样的，
是要经历打击，
是要听了某种课程，
还是他天生有的这个物型，
那个意义是从何而来的？
嗯，很好的问题啊，
我是有两个原因开始的，
最大的原因是，
我开始做爸爸了以后，
发现说我不太喜欢做爸爸，
而且也不懂怎么做爸爸，
我当时在微博刚刚出来的时候，
我给自己的一个微博上的作用名，
就是一个完美的老公，
但是一个只是OK的爸爸，
就当时我给自己的定义，
这个其实说的听上去很随意啊，
但实际上我内心有很多的责备，
就有很多的疑问有种羞耻，
说是不是好像我在措施了很多东西，
所以从那个时候，
我开始去跟一些老师去接触了，
当时我也没有想到说，
这个真我这种东西从来没有想到，
只是觉得，
我的生命中有些东西我想去改变，
一个人走上一条自我探索的路啊，
我觉得至少有个四五个不同的，
一步一步的这个朝前走的一个阶梯吧，
第一个阶梯是刚才我说到的，
就是发现有些东西我想改变，
不太能够接受这个东西，
我想改变，
或者是我需要一个东西，
这是第一步，
看到了一个想要改变的，
就不能接受的一个东西，
第二步呢，
是决定这个东西是有可能改变的，
这个其实我觉得也是很大的一步，
很多人觉得自己我就这回事了，
我也不喜欢这一步，
但这回我想变，
但是它其实内心深处啊，
不决制的东西是有可能改变的，
但第一步和第二步有时候是，
两个可能都同时都要发生的事情，
就是一个是发现我不能接受的东西，
第二个决定，
这个东西其实是有可能别会变化的，
比如说我对朋友这件事情，
我可能真的感觉上有可能的话，
可能最近十几年的事情发现，
这个真的是有可能变化的，
第三个是我决定真的花时间去变化，
这个对于有些人来可能是，
从第一步做到第三步，
可能需要好多年的时间都有可能的，
花时间的话可能是去探索我自己为什么，
我对朋友这件事情有羞耻感，
或者有一种恐惧，
这些东西开始进行探索了，
我这是第三步，
就真正的去找到老师，
找到方法去进行探索，
这一步走出来的话，
还是得到正反馈以后的话呢，
第四步呢，
我的感受是，
有点像举一反三的发现说，
这块地方我可以变化的，
但是其实还有一些别的地方，
其实我之前没有这么大动力去变化，
但是现在我知道有可能变化了，
我也想去探索这方面的东西了，
比如说我太太的话，
她第一步她说的是跟她妈妈的关系，
她花了三十多年觉得没问题，
她觉得她跟妈妈关系是完美的，
直到三十多岁以后发现有件事情发生的话，
说这个真的是不行，
接近十年的事情把这件事情扭过来了，
从中就过程发现说，
其实她的童年对她有很多的烙印，
是限制她的生命的展放的，
但是这个过了以后，
接下来说那说不定还有别的东西我可以变的，
整个人就对自我的认定就松动了，
然后就愿意去更多的探索所谓的，
可和真我的区别，
然后第五个阶段是一种完全为了真实，
而不是解决问题的，
有些人可能永远不会进入第五阶段，
我觉得要看自己一个动力的，不是一个好和坏，
因为第四阶段还是在解决问题，
我发现有别的问题我想解决的，我想改变的，
但是到了最深的一个阶段的时候的话，
至于我现在的这种感觉，
或者我的太太也发现慢慢进入这种状态，
就说当然解决问题让我生命更美好，
还是想要的，
但是有一种开始跟一种更深层次的动力在连接，
就说我就想做我真正的我，
我就想跟真我去连接，
没有为什么，
因为你就叫Truth for its own sake,。
只是为了事实去去去寻找真，
进入这个时候的话，
我的感受是又美好很难形容，
是一种动力，也是一种状态，
有很多的感激，
觉得我能够有这个机会找到好的老师，
能够进入这样一个状态，
把我生命的这些，
原来这样寻真的这些能量能够倒动起来，
所以这是我想分享这个五个阶段，
你怎么看的？
好难呀，
就是人要真正做到这些事情好难，
因为当你在说的时候，
我也在回忆我自己，
不可问我的妈妈，
我觉得走到这一步真的很难，
就像我跟我妈吵架，
我有的时候能看见我的情绪是无名之火，
我有时候也能看见他的那个应急反应，
是带着他自己深重的业力，
但仍然在我们的对话过程中，
爆发这些情绪，
是失控的，是惯性的，
你哪怕底层有深深的爱与信任，
都很难在他的表面表达出来的一种人的故质性，
所以一个人你要可以克服自己惯性的那种，
比如我就是这样子的人，
就是那些对自己固化的认知，
那种对自己的确信，
是一件就是一个充满风险之旅，
因为当你打破你的固化的时候，
你有很多堵定的东西，
你会变得不确定，
他有可能会让你迷茫，
甚至原有的自信也没有了，
我相信有的人经历过这个过程的，
然后他退回去了，
他会发现好吓人，好恐怖，
我原来的安全感也没了，
不要再进步了，我退回去就好，
有的人他可能会跟往前走那一步，
我想那一步，
你真正可以把你的认知转化成行动的时候，
我给你举个例子，
我前阵子不是滑雪受伤了吗？
我本来以为这是个小伤，
可能养几周就好了，
回到北京的时候，
准备做康复训练，
我第一天见了一个康复医生，
他就跟我说，
你这个认诞已经完全没有弹性了，
你得做手术，
因为他说这个认诞是个永久性伤害，
不太能够再做剧烈运动了，
然后我又去找了第二个康复师，
然后第二个康复师说，
你这个没毛病，
拉一拉你自己锻炼锻炼就好了，
但是你确实不太在做剧烈运动了，
如果你非要做呢，
你就等他做的时候断了，
那你就到时候再做手术，
然后我又去找了很厉害的医生，
这个医生给我拍完片子之后说，
我不介意你做手术，
但你确实不能再做剧烈运动了，
这个剧烈运动主要是指滑雪，
我就说我特别想滑雪，
他说这个雪你是非滑不可，
你就不能骑个车游个泳，
我说我可以骑车游泳，
但我就是想滑雪，
因为我觉得我刚刚喜欢上滑雪，
我还没有好好滑雪，
还没有享受它，
我就被剥夺了滑雪的权利，
我不行，他就说那你还得做手术，
接下来我又开始打听，
这个手术到底做哪一种怎么做，
等于系列，
然后昨天晚上我又见了一个康复医生，
强烈建议我不要做手术，
但是我要经过漫长的训练，
因为他说其实你做完手术，
还得经过这一趟训练，
不如你先训练，
我是那种特别难做那种，
小儿需要坚持的事情的人，
比如说每天被五个单词，
或者每天做十个氧，
我起座我都做不到，
我只能做那种很大的，
很复杂的，
很需要冲劲的事，
我可以几天几天不睡觉，
把这事干了，
但是简单的重复的小事，
对我来说就是巨大的挑战，
我之所以想讲这个故事，
是因为我问了我自己很久，
我到底是不是真的想化学，
然后我发现我是真的想化学，
所以我决定要开始这个断，
艰难的康复之旅，
所以我想人的那个行动，
他是被一个巨大的院里牵引着，
你才可能真的去行动呢，
要不然你的恐惧，
你出常试之后的失败，
你的不被理解，
任何一个层面，
方方面的原因，
都可能把你打回原形，
可能让你往回退，
是的,
我觉得要改变，
小时候记得有很多人在这种讨论，
说人能不能真的变，
我现在的感觉是可以的，
但是呢很难，
就是你说的很难，
然后变的动力，
只有两种可能性，
百分之九十和百分之十，
百分之九十呢，
是出现一个情况，
说我无法接受这个情况，
不改变我真的觉得就是不行了，
我真的是不能接受不改变，
另外还有百分之十的可能性，
是我看到一个愿景，
可能是别人身上发生的，
或者是我很想要的一个愿景，
我可以描述一个愿景，
这个是我想活的生命的样子，
这种愿景也可以去动，
但是呢比较少的人，
老实说能够被这个东西持续的去动，
更多的去动力来自于，
这个东西我现在就真的活不下去了，
一滑雪的话，
这个有点像是第二种去动的感觉，
那就确实这个改变的动力很难，
我的感觉呢是，
当我们尝到了一个甜头以后，
就会有更多的动力会出现，
所以有时候改变一个小的事情，
比较容易一些，
先从一个小的点开始做，
然后发现有进步的时候，
有自由了，有更多的愉悦的时候的话，
就会有更多动力去做，
下个更大的改变，
而且确实你说的这个，
走入这个跟市长这条路，
不是说就一帆风声越来越好的，
会有一些新的恐惧会出现，
我是从前我以为是没有任何的焦虑的人，
我觉得我这个人是从来不会焦虑，
孩子说了一些事情，
也有发现说我真的是有焦虑的，
而且要承认我有焦虑这个事情，
花了至少半年的时间，
感受很不好，
但走入一个低谷以后，
当我后来走出来的时候，
发现说我因为走过这条路的话，
我的生命就多了一个层次的，
一个新的一个，
甚至可以数量级的自由，
还有另外一个呢，
我想分享的是，
不知道你碰到的时候，
有没有这种感觉，
我们是两年多以前碰到的嘛，对不对？
2022年,
不止了，
四年了，
当时我其实是很想做好人的，
想做善事做好人的，
不然当时你有这种感受吗？
感觉到，
非常强烈，
我为什么有当时这么强烈的感觉，
其实我内心觉得我不是好人，
我需要通过做事情，
我才能去，
让自己感受到自己是做好人，
其实也是一种新的这种，
壳的一种处理方法，
去当时是一种，
假的真我连接吧，
我觉得这个其实有些修行的人，
也会出现同样的问题，
就是说都想做好事，
或者说就是，
其实通过做好事，
现在想想是给我自己带来一种，
自我肯定的一种感觉吧，
就像从前是通过，
数学第一名的各自我肯定，
后来变成商业要成功，
不用自我肯定，
后来变成我要做善事，
变成一个自我肯定，
其实变汤没有变料，
又想听听你当时对我的感受是怎么样的。
首先我很佩服你在做的事情，
我觉得你在做一些极其难，
而且可能不会有人想到要做的事情，
我对你的理解是说，
你在个人的成长过程中，
其实,
觉察到，
我们的社会系统教了我们很多技术，
有如何成功，
如何进步，
如何学习，
但没有人帮助我们实现，
如何成为一个更真实的人，
从而走向幸福。
所以我的理解是，
你在做一件，
通过跟自我更好的连接，
从而有走向幸福的机会的一件事情。
做这件事情，做成这样的事情，
一个结果是，
我们自己会，
长久我很有坚信，
可以更幸福，
这是我很有信心的，
是会有曲折的，
不是一个顺的，
更幸福，
更自由，
更有能量，
这是一方面。
另外一方面，
我觉得每个人做的事情，
对世界的帮助，
对世界的正面的影响，
不是多个百分之十，
可能多个百分之一百，
一千都有可能，
当然要帮助这个社会，
有很多的方法可以做，
只是我觉得这个方法，
是我自己有亲身体验的。
说回这个个人修行的事情，
我的一个深刻的感受是，
他是没法劝来的，
是的,
就像有的人，
你劝了他半天，
他答应你了，
他最后又不来，
是因为他内心，
没有觉得自己有这个需求，
就像我，
我们当时不是觉得我有需求，
但是我有好奇心，
就是我至少想知道，
是怎么回事，
再来判断一下，
我有没有需求，
有的人其实非常有需求，
但他自己不认为，
不愿意花出这个时间成本，
去做这个尝试，
但没有到那个，
真的要去解决这个问题的状态，
所以他也就不是，
你要去吸引的人。
很有可能是的，
对的，是的。
那回到你刚才说到的，
我刚才打断你的说道，
对善事这件事情，
做好事这件事情，
做好人，
所谓的好人这件事情的话，
怎么看，
因为从某种角度来说，
天真,
为什么很多人喜欢你，
这是我的感觉，
是因为你走出一条路，
这一种，
撒脱的，
一种活的方法，
东方文化，
跟西方文化不一样，
东方文化就是，
这个责任，
父母的责任，
各种责任，
各种责任对待身上，
就没有自由了，
所以我这是我的感觉，
是不知道我这样说的对不对，
这个责任和，
做好人，
所谓做好人，
善事这块的话，
这个区别在那里，
或者是怎么来看这件事情呢，
觉得。
我经常会在我们公司讲一些，
被我们合伙人团队批评，
不负责任的话，
就是有时候会唱碎我们的行业，
然后他跟我说，
你不能这样子，
他都还在这个行业工作，
你如此不看好，
你让大家怎么安心工作呢，
但我觉得，
我不看好是个事实，
我怎么能讲假话呢，
我可能可以选择，
更好的表达方式，
不是以打击的方式，
来说出这件事情，
是可以的，
这是我需要修炼的部分，
但是我没有办法，
讲假话，
就假设你看到一条船要沉了，
这条船沉的速度慢一点，
你不告诉大家，
这条船要沉，
最后很多人可能会淹死的，
所以我觉得你得说出来，
所以我觉得我要去练习的是，
找到一个更好的方法，
让大家都安全的着陆，
而不是只说，
哎呀，船要沉了，
这其实也是一种不负责任，
对，是的，
所以这是我自己要修炼，
修炼的部分，
我想我的这种，
不负责任的，
这个打双一号的不负责任，
是基于两个东西，
第一个是，
对自己能力边界的认知，
我做不了那么多事，
我也负不了那么多责，
第二个是，
我有一个优先级，
就是在所有的事情里面，
我都觉得先保护好自己，
是很优先的，
但是我并不主张，
只保护自己，
因为只保护自己，
就是彻头彻底的自私，
但是先保护自己，
是守卫一种能量，
就像我们在飞机上，
你去学习这个，
紧急救援，
紧急时刻，
都是要先照顾好自己的，
然后有余力的情况下，
去照顾别人，
我对做善事怎么看，
我觉得有两种，
有一种人是把做善事当成是工作，
工作没有性质的区别，
所谓的善事，
本质上都是你对工作的选择，
然后第二种情况是，
有的人，
他是把做善事当成了一种社交手段，
我见过一些，
就是某些人吧，
他是用这样的身份做一个人设，
他有了这个人设之后，
他比较获得他人的敬佩，
所谓有职业光环，
仿佛他是一个不计较公民利路，
然后只为他人着想的人，
有的人是沉迷于这种光环，
并不是喜欢这件事情本身，
所以我觉得人的初心非常重要，
帮助人有几个层次，
第一个层次叫做好人有好报，
就你做事情是为了自己的福报，
第二个层次叫做助人为快乐之本，
你不求具体的回报，
但你求你心里快乐，
你就会感受到，
我是一个好人，
我挺好的，
是一种愉悦感，
第三个层次叫做，
他只是在做一件事情，
就是我应该做的，
这是一种我比较向往的层次，
就是你没把他当成一个慈善，
也没把他当成一个好事，
你就是想做这件事情，
随手的帮助别人，
或者是哪怕在一件，
一件事命运推到你的面前，
你能够去做，你就去做它，
它是非常自然的，
没什么了不起的，
善与恶的定义很多时候是，
或者它高价值感是，
社会给予它的一种包奖，
是为了鼓励大家都这样子去做，
而给予一种额外的包奖，
但它本质上，
其实没什么了不起的。
对，我的理解是这样啊，
就是说，
我们如果还是用壳，
跟真我这个角度来看的话，
是,
如果所谓的要去做好事的话，
一种方法是，
让我的壳更光鲜，
让我觉得自己这种感受更好，
给别人看的，
另外一种呢，
是自然的驱动，
我为了别人，
其实也是为了自己，
这个事情，
一定是在你的本质剧桌之后，
才会发生的。
我觉得是这样，
我自己的感受是，
当我用一种，
连接的态度，
去跟所有人，
我可能，
不能完全做到，
但是我能做到的时候，
其实我的内心是很快乐，
很愉悦的，
其实有时候，
你所谓的做一件善事，
还不如，
在生命的最小的一个，
小的一个时刻，
对另外一个人有一个善意。
我非常同意这一点，
你说的那种善意就特别重要，
就是当你在生活中，
真的尊重每一个人，
可能与那种大善相比，
日行的这个善，
就是你带着善意的善，
你当一个人带着善意的时候，
觉得你的intention不一样，
你的整个行为就会不一样。
能不能，
最后一个事情想问你，
就是说，
在一两天以前，
你当时有给我分享过一个东西，
我可不可以问你这个事情，
你说到就是，
你从前是觉得，
我为了自己要活得爽快，
但是如果要，
比如跟一个朋友一起去出去玩，
我对他有一种责任，
对我就是限制了，
如果我们立即解错的说，
你现在对这件事情有个不同的一种看法，
对，我曾经有举个例子，
有说我们几个朋友旅行，
我们订了一家餐厅，
然后另外一个朋友呢，
打电话远程安排了一家餐厅，
他都付过钱，
然后精心准备好了那个餐厅，
他说很好吃，你们要去吃，
但是我当时的倔强劲，
我有饭，
你为什么要不经我的允许，
安排我的行程，
就是我明明有自己想去吃的东西，
然后其他几个人就觉得很不好意思，
说人家都安排了，咱们就去吧，
我说行，那你们去吧，
我要去吃我要吃的餐厅，
于是我就把大家弄得都很不开心，
我一直颜值早早的觉得我做得非常对，
我觉得我在保护自己的感受，
但是今天的我，
可能不会做这样的选择了，
我会觉得接受他的善意，
比我吃那一段我想吃的饭重要，
就是你在跟一个人的关系中，
你们是有一个共同的目标的，
这共同的目标就是你也要开心，
我也要开心，
而我觉得我过去很多时刻的选择，
是只有我开心，
然后你们都得跟着我开心啊，
是这种状态，
但现在我不意识到，
其实那时他们跟我不计较，
是他们包容了我，
不是因为我做对了，
这个是我意识到，
如果你想要一个好的关系，
你必须得以你们共同的利益为一个目标，
这样才可能是这个关系是相容的，
是圆容的，是一个持续的关系，
而且我，
当时做这个安排的朋友，
现在已经过世了，
可能我也没有机会给他道歉了，
我想你今天这样说的时候的话，
我的感受，
他在上天里面应该知道的，
你有这样一个想法的时候，
你甚至不用说，
他现在一定是知道的，
我们的生命是非常有限的，
我想我们能遇到的人，
那些对你有善意的人，
都是应该一句好珍惜的，
虽然我可能，
还是会有很多的自我和任性，
但是我同样，
也感受到自己的一些变化，
一些对于真相，
对于真我，
就是我会用一种更柔软的方式，
表达自己，
我过去是非常非常的，
要表达自己的，
但那个表达的方式很锐利，
很shake,
很坚固，
他带来了一种爽感，
但同样，
他的疯忙也会伤害很多人，
我希望我，
接下来，
依旧能保留完整的自己，
依旧能够照顾好自己的内心，
但是我可以选择，
这种柔和的方式，
尽量减少伤害他人的方式，
不冒犯他人的方式，
依旧保持自己，
其实是可以做到的。
我相信一定可以做到的，
而且过程中，
也会更真，
谢谢你，田真，
今天这么的真，
我在刚开始说，
真的很喜欢你，
这次感觉更有更多的联系，
很感谢你，
能够做起来，
而且这次来，
跟你聊的这么的真实，
谢谢你。
我也谢谢你，
在几年前，
给了我家一个可以走上内心，
自我探寻之路的机会，
我觉得他彻底的改变了我。
谢谢,
爱你!